the next thing says find the speed at
which the ball was thrown have a look at
your table speed
what's that course they related to
velocity right it's going to be related
to velocity the difference is velocity
includes up or down and speed doesn't
okay so let's go ahead and try and work
out speed because speed is connected to
velocity but it's like velocity when
plus or minus doesn't matter one of the
ways we can do this is to apply absolute
value science to it because that's a way
of saying I disregard whether it is
positive or negative right it says when
the ball was thrown what time was that
at time zero right so this is where the
ball starts going so I'm gonna say when
T equals zero and then I'm going to
substitute into the right equation which
in this case is the absolute value of
velocity absolute value of V so what's
my velocity equation twenty take away
ten lots of what zero that's the thing
I'm substituting right so it's twenty
take away zero which is twenty right now
that's the number but when you have a
look it says like tell me what the speed
was so that's why the very first thing
we wrote down with the unit's that
applied right I rubbed it off already
you know frequently we use kilometers
per hour but that's not what this
question is this question is meters per
second so I'm going to conclude this is
really important I'm gonna say speed was
20 meters per second okay so it's really
important you can could use some actual
words and the units that are relevant
okay what is Patsy asked and we'll go
right with me bless you find when it
returns to the ground even sort of helps
you out that's when x equals zero
because that's our vertical axis and
show that it's speed there is equivalent
or equal rather to the initial speed now
we've actually because we drew it we
already kind of know this right I can
say from the graph we know that X starts
off at zero when does it come back to x
equals zero at time equals four right so
from the graph what's the word it says
it returns to the ground
and normally we would say like at x
equals something or some way that but
I'm gonna say when time equals four so
after four seconds right now how do I
answer this next part how do I show that
it's speed then is equal to the initial
speed how do I find this speed again
yeah I looked at the velocity function
and I substituted in the specific time
which in that case was zero this time
I'm going to substitute a different time
the landing time right yeah so I'm gonna
say when T equals four and again whereas
you had speed not velocity so I'm going
to put some absolute value signs around
me to indicate I'm doing speed equals
then I'm gonna go straight back to my
velocity equation it's 20 take away 10
lots of what 4 because that's the time
I'm substituting in like so
so this is the absolute value of 20 take
away 40 we're gonna get negative 20 in
there so you can see oh great this is
speed because that's why I apply the
absolute value sign so you can see
that's equivalent so this is 20 meters
per second at landing I guess we could
say or at return to ground okay so it's
the same great
party we're on the home stretch right
find its maximum height above the ground
and the time taken to reach this height
now I'm actually going to suggest it's
easy to answer that in Reverse we want
to find a time that makes that maximum
height you can even see it on your graph
right and then we will take that time
and substitute it in what does the time
look like is your graph good enough to
be able to just read it off so number
one we're talking seconds so four
minutes is a long way off here okay
secondly for is here I've within a
second so I want something that
corresponds to that spot right that's
gonna be yeah T equals 2 because
parameters have symmetry right the axis
of symmetry is there it's worth noting
that often you won't have graphs so nice
and neat you can't just read off
symmetry of a cubic function for example
so what would you have to do by the way
if you were searching for this point if
you couldn't just look at it you'll be
looking for a stationary point when you
or more specifically a turning point so
you're gonna have to go to your
derivatives and then try and stall okay
all right so let's go ahead let's take
that time when T equals two I've got
three equations X V and a which one am i
substituting into to answer this
question look carefully
what's it asking yes is going the first
equation right because it says find the
maximum height now these velocity
acceleration equations don't tell you
where you are they tell you what's
happening at those spots
I need my X equation my displacement so
I'm going to say when T equals two x
equals and let's do the substitution
okay 20 lots of to take away five lots
of to square anyone help me out what's
the next longer me
forty take away five lots of four which
is 20 okay now this number is the same
but because I've put into a different
equation than previously it means
something different right
this means it's 20 meters high 20 meters
above the ground right so therefore I
would say highest point is 20 meters
above the ground and please please use
words like this which describe like
you're 20 meters what is it it might not
be above the ground it might be like
from the top of a building right or it
might be below a cliff or it could be
anything
it is never assumed it is never ever
assumed which is why I'm trying to make
a big deal out of it okay you must
always stay what's going on last
question I can't even remember what it
says by this point it says find the
acceleration at the top of the flight
and explain why let's get to that
explain stuff after we find the first
part what is the acceleration at the top
what we actually know acceleration have
a look at your graph down here
acceleration is constant it's always
this number right so I can say patty go
down a minute party a is going to always
be equal to negative 10 I actually don't
care what value of t it is but if I had
some other acceleration equation
I'd say substitute equals 2 into there
and you get some value okay now what
does this mean I haven't actually
answered the question right I would say
therefore acceleration is now pause
displacement units are meters velocity
units meters per second
what are acceleration units yes so the
physics people have encountered this
before but for those of you can't
remember but you're still measuring in
meters
you're still measuring in seconds but
because you're measuring velocity in
seconds and that's meters per second its
meters per second per second and the way
we write that is 10 meters per second
squared or occasionally you'll see this
with a negative in debt
10 meters per second with a negative
tune you all equally frequently see
those kinds of notations used okay or
you might even hear them say 10 meters
per second per second and by the way 10
meters per second per second that's not
a number that was plucked out of thin
air this thing got thrown up and then it
came back down what was the the thing
acting on the ball that brought it back
down to the ground gravity which is
roughly 9.8 meters per second per second
and you'll see 10 frequently used now
the acceleration is 10 meters per second
per second which way up or down look
carefully
we're carefully what this graph tells me
right that negative means downward right
so I have to say that it's 10 meters per
second per second in the downward
direction question
this negative two right here yep yeah
the difference between these is and
their different ways of saying the same
thing like that negative index is a way
to divide right so it's this per meters
per second the per actually means
division right so I can use a negative
index to me now okay I've run out of
space but we have one last question to
answer
it says explain why the explora
acceleration can be nonzero its it's not
zero it's ten in the down direction when
the ball is stationary like the balls
not moving how can there be acceleration
when the balls not going anywhere
hmm now you might hear this idea of like
we talked about the word deceleration
before I'm consciously not going to use
that because it's actually very
confusing but there is like to take the
idea here the ball was slowing down
right we're slowing down
it was it we threw it up okay it slowed
down until it got to that point but
guess what it's still changing velocity
right it's slowing down event starts
speeding up I guess back toward the
ground but the whole point is go back to
your table right acceleration is
remember any change in velocity any
change positive or negative slowing to
speeding up slowing down because there's
a change in velocity that means as the
graph tells us there is acceleration but
it's not zero okay and like you guys
told me before it's gravity in this case
all the calculus stuff that you're doing
here is actually fairly rudimentary it's
like oh you won't get really crazy
weirdo functions your derailer trainer
wants you differentiate again but
there's a lot of interpretation extra
language which you have to say Oh what
does it mean when they say initially it
means time equals zero right what does
it mean when they say you know this
direction or that direction you have to
interpret the sign whether it's positive
or negative okay